I met Tom Arnold I remember his
assistant Vinny
Brad his barbecue and Tom was like hey
what we love we love Tom ours I'm his
son's Godfather sons
yeah Godfather we're there and he goes
hey hey give me a [ __ ] hot dog he's
just kind of beaten you know dick Tom's
a lovable guy but he's Benedict that day
and he's like [ __ ] man ha can I go Vinny
let me get this hot dog he's like ok so
I went and I put my dick my human penis
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thank you it's so funny that you say
that because when we did the premiere of
kicking it old school he left early Tom
yes no Jack Shepherd Oh Jax was sitting
next to me in the theater and text me
during the movie goes this movie so bad
I can't believe I'm not we all do bad
words but we had the best time of our
lives
in terms of like fun that was a great
time because it was like you would you
know you meet guys like Michael and you
go all these are my kindred kindred
spirits that you meet guys that are like
playful and not Hollywood they're like
just funny this dude is so [ __ ] funny
and he's an he's a great actor right but
you you you're surprised how his timing
he's a comic Wow
Michael rose above is a con I'm working
my way you know and you know what he
said to me outside baby no no the he
might try stand up there are a few
people cuz I've I've seen enough people
there are a few people who he he
encourages to do standards like yeah I'm
just like will
yes it absolutely makes sense for you I
mean I've only talked to you for 10
minutes absolutely a thousand percent
makes it yeah when I masturbate to you I
love your nipples I don't tell many
people this but yes you should do the
stand-up thing man yeah you're doing
freshens you're always know better than
most these [ __ ] guys got there dude
[ __ ] the [ __ ] gonna happen bud
something you've told me and then jo koy
you know Joe yeah yeah you die if I bomb
who cares have you bombed all the time
asked him already do Irvine with them in
January yeah
in January it was I thought it was more
no it's January coming is this third
week of ginger week of January yeah we
do it you have to do it just do like
seven minutes because I'm gonna say this
will sasso did it last time was the last
over two years ago he was amazing yeah
really yeah and he hadn't he doesn't do
staff he had never done it no and he
went into the character wore a wig and
he went up with a costume but still he
went up right that's the most important
thing I know you just can't worry about
anything you just gotta go up do it and
just get your dick I just say something
right now I did a show in San Jose where
I got booed off a stage at three forty
thousand people opened for yeah I got
opened for a cat I've told the story
before was Katt Williams Chapelle a
bunch of people are on the line up I was
supposed to do 20 minutes I did two
minutes I got booed off the stage would
you open with let me just mention I
don't remember because I was bombing so
hard I blacked out like it was a foot of
that many of you were so nervous no
wasn't nervous I had to follow Leslie
Jones and I've talked about it before in
the podcast but right it was terrible
and I after the experience I was in this
like room with my agent and stuff and
everyone was laughing how bad I was and
I
over it he took a couple of days not so
you get booted off a stage in front of
that movie boat it takes a couple of
days but then you go you know what I'm
gonna do it again I just did the oddball
tour it wasn't as many people it was
more like seven eight thousand but still
I remember I had to remember that
experience and I went you know what it's
okay I'm gonna live through it and I did
great you know but I'm I'm I know that
it won't kill me from bombing and I know
that I've learned so much from bombing
you know your name isn't Rosenbaum
here's another grandpa Lou ball Joe yeah
but also I would set it up I would set
it up in a way with a host however you
wanted to do it maybe his first time or
whatever I might be but it's gonna be a
very comfortable nurturing experience if
you did it do you is that what you want
that you want people to go in kind of
going oh he's slow here we go no I don't
think you should tell him that it's his
first time I don't know what it it's a
that's a handicap every time don't make
him go play video games
[Music]